the Memphis PD announced over the
weekend it is permanently disbanding the
specialized unit involved in the death
of Tyree Nichols all five officers
charged in his death were part of the
so-called scorpion unit created in 2021
to Target violent crime at first it was
seen as a success but as Jeff piguace
reports there are questions now about
what successful policing really looks
like
scorpion which is short for the street
crimes operation to restore peace in our
neighborhoods was created to reduce
Rising crime in Memphis the police
department's 40 officer unit focused on
violent offenses like homicides assaults
robberies and carjackings but just over
a year after it was created the squad
was disbanded permanently on Saturday
after five of its officers were fired
and charred with second-degree murder in
the death of Tyree Nichols you guys are
really doing a lot right now brutal
tactics the officers used are on display
in the video released on Friday after
beating in pepper spraying Nichols who
was unarmed the officers were seen
chatting as he sat propped up against a
police car I don't know where y'all see
him right here he was running through
the yard bro the culture is an issue
that has to be looked at and there has
to be a surgical look Memphis police
chief Sarah Lynn Davis told CBS News
members of this unit somehow strayed
from the mission it was it set up so
that officers can be heavy-handed and
these officers were supposed to have
laser focus sort of priorities on repeat
offenders those are individuals that
were committing violent crimes and they
had great success last year how do you
really quantify success retired NYPD
detective Mark Claxton now with a black
law enforcement Alliance says in his
experience these specialized units can
breed their own toxic culture when you
have these smaller individualized units
that can develop this subculture but
they all operate within the the the
purview of that larger toxic police
culture it's just that they're more
insular they're more secretive while
Advocates applaud the disbanding of the
Scorpion unit some are now calling on
Washington to act on police reform after
a bill named for George Floyd failed to
get through the last Congress it had
many elements in it that are important
Banning choke holds dealing with no
warrant searches dealing with
accreditation of police departments but
without the chair
yeah a tough road to passage I don't
know that there's any law that can stop
that evil that we saw
the chairman of the Congressional Black
Caucus is requesting a meeting with
President Biden this week to discuss
police reform issues specifically police
misconduct a date though has not yet
been set glad
Jeff thank you very much you know guys
as painful as that video is to watch I'm
actually glad there is video because
without the video there would be a
different story you see them on the tape
at one point saying well you know he
tried to grab my gun you see that video
you know there's no way that guy tried
he was 140 150 pounds with those office
who were clearly very large yeah it's
it's heartbreaking though to watch this
it's incredibly disturbing to listen to
officers trying to get their stories
straight as to what happened when we
have the video and we can see with our
own eyes what happened but as a nation
as we mourn Tyree Nichols though we also
turn to the bigger conversation of what
we do about policing in America because
Memphis like many communities I mean
part of Scorpion's acronym was restoring
peace to our neighborhoods a lot of
people want that as well crime needs to
be brought down there was a significant
spike in violent crimes and murders in
the in the city of Memphis and the city
was trying to Grapple with that yeah